[Music]
just three episodes of a dystopian
fan-favorite series black mirror have
landed on Netflix as with other seasons
showrunners Charlie Brooker and Annabel
Jones have included some Easter eggs and
nods to previous episodes we've taken a
forensic deep dive to show you 34 things
that you might have missed in season 5
of Black Mirror
warning if you haven't seen the latest
season you might want to look away now
Episode one striking Vipers dolls
Avengers actor Anthony Mackie as a man
romantically linked to a VR game the
game Mackey's character Danny is gifted
it's made by TCK are you might recognize
a neural research company from the
season 4 episode black Museum it
developed the pain diagnostic service
used by dr. Peter Dawson the company
also developed the alternative reality
simulator in the beloved episode sanjeev
pero the acronym TC KR is also
referenced in the bar named tacos in
that episode the idea of augmented
reality gaming isn't viewed to black
mirror it's the premise for play test
the episode in which t ck our systems is
also referenced briefly in the magazine
headline think the production design in
costumes look a bit familiar the
pastoral palette bears an uncanny
resemblance to the community in season
three's nosedive in order to access the
game Danny and Cole have to put small
round devices onto their temples similar
technology is also seen throughout the
seasons as a mind-reading device in
crocodile or to extract consciousness
and black museum when Danny opens his
cupboard to put the game away we can
visibly see an out-of-place looking blue
convertible model on the shelf retro
cars make an appearance in several black
mirror episodes such as black Museum and
San Junipero it's episode 2 smithereen
where we start to see tons of references
it stars sherlock actor Andrew Scott as
a disillusioned rideshare driver who
takes an intern from an Internet privacy
company hostage the episode makes no
secret of Brooker and Jones's attitude
towards smartphone addiction the payoff
about Scott causing death by dangerous
driving because he was checking his
phone is a recognizable theme about the
dangers of app usage we've seen it in
nosedive and shut up and dance
you might not recognize the name of the
episode unless if you got to one of the
many endings of Bandersnatch in which
you KN news footage of Stefan's game is
played with accrual across the bottom of
the screen this reads Senate committee
grilled smithereen CEO Biddy Bauer over
Russian BOTS the episode opens with
Scotts character Chris picking up a ride
in central London the real-life location
of the shady smithereen corporation it's
actually Bloomberg HQ on a Google map
drop it takes us to wallbrook just
outside of Bloomberg and the City of
London Magistrates Court but it's the
close up of the ride share app address
that's particularly interesting we
learned that the rider is picking up
from Sky Lane Street ec4 n sky Lane was
one of the names of the planets in u.s.
s Callister skyline fall and ranek
victorious car Lane is the name of the
killer in season two's white birth her
name also crops up in the hashtags feed
in haters in the nation as hashtag des
two victorious Gallade also in this
frame we see Bandersnatch theater a
reference to Bandersnatch romans which
turned david the antagonist in men
against fire and dolls after vanessa
doll in hated in the nation there's also
Redfield theater after Cooper Redfield
the protagonist and playtest
Dawson's bergerbar who is the doctor in
black Museum and there's two more
interesting place names the first is
hugs I suppose I'd nod to Charlie
broker's wife Connie hug who's a TV
personality in the UK the second is
fences pizza this takeout joint was also
featured in USS Callister and crocodile
we see an empty fences pizza box later
on in smithereen when police raid
critters house a quick look at a phone
also gives us some references to other
characters in other episodes
Colton Blum the main antagonist of the
national anthem is in there as is
Clayton Lee the abused prisoner in black
Museum these characters have such
disparate lives in the BlackBerry
universe that it's hard to imagine these
numbers reference the actual characters
Chris drives past a BRB connect petrol
station fans might recognize this gas
station chain from black museum as well
as the acronym BRB be right back from
season 2 episode 1 an eagle-eyed reddit
user also spotted BRB appears on the
login screen in metalhead where
abbreviations for all the season 4
episode names are shown then we go to
the interiors of smithereen HQ there's a
news car saying Prime Minister callow to
meet with EU negotiators in Brussels in
reference to Prime Minister callow from
season 1 episode 1 the hashtag snout
rage also presumably refers to this
episode too but take a closer look at
some of the other hashtags hashtag
Ashley Oh Wembley previews Miley Cyrus's
gig in the following episode Rachael
Jack and Ashley - also hashtagged our
hashtag sea of tranquillity reboot and
hashtag site o X Netflix which suggests
that the company from play test has
bought out a new game or series with
Netflix hashtag sake juniper strike is
also on screen which refers to the
fictional hospital's sake junipers from
black museum interestingly this shows
the smithereen nosedive plato's black
museum and the national anthem all take
place in the same time in the same
universe also because it's Charlie
Brooker the seemingly mundane BBC show
bargain hunt it's also trending any
Radiohead fans out there if you weren't
content with exit music for a film being
used in shut up a dance this episode
also features a 2016 song daydreaming
moving on to episode three Rachael Jack
and Ashley - who plays with Miley
Cyrus's own experiences as a pop icon as
she is forced to repress elements of her
own personality to become a palatable
bite-sized toy consciousness Ashley -
the episode makes two really great
references to modern pop stardom
the first is clone theory that pop stars
like Avril Lavigne and Taylor Swift have
actually been replaced with clones and
aren't who they say they are
the second is hologram technology
artists like Mariah Carey have been
criticized for embracing hologram
versions of themselves which can
simultaneously perform at different
venues around the world
Brook and Jones seem to be suggesting
through Ashley's hologram that this
isn't a true representation of the
singer and so shouldn't be pursued the
transplant Tech featured in this episode
isn't new to Black Mirror in white
Christmas and black Museum we've seen
the perils of transplanted consciousness
from a person into an inanimate object
in an interesting time overlap we see
that the rapper tusks from hasty
imitation is making headlines on a
newscast we see the new sir along with a
striking Vipers reference museum owners
body found in smoking ruins surely this
is a nod to the events of black museum
Simpsons fans might feel little deja vu
at the line believe in yourself you can
do anything the fossil line spouted by
Ashley - it's eerily similar to trusted
yourself and you can achieve anything
that the dole lease alone heart makes
word Lisa Simpson also called Brooke a
fans might have noticed that teddy bears
crop up across a series as does a
sinister organization white bear this
time it's the name of a shady security
guard
we finally got a nod to Charlie Brooker
series Nathan barley the series about an
East London creative was a satire on
media life in the mid-2000s in it a
character gets in sugar ape magazine the
magazine with a different cover star is
pictured hanging on the wall of a record
company the series ends with the
characters exiting Bob's music venue bob
was the name of the antagonist in USS
Callister hinting that Ashley O has
embraced her darker side think you
spotted anything that we've missed
comment below
you
[Music]